legit after this interview we got we got
a talk
and i'm talking sexually because i'm
turned on as well jesus
hey yo what's up it's your boy ksi and
today i'm going to be interviewing
someone who's
very special to me myself
hey my g how you doing good how are you
i'm very good
geez if i was single oh you dirty dog
nah man you're fit you're
sexy i mean you're not oh my god
you're unreal damn but
you're working out as well oh my god
all right if you could describe yourself
in three words
which words would you use we were to
describe myself
sexy okay yeah yeah
uh funny oh you are pretty much
a winner
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're not going to go for knowledge
strength and integrity
i
what's your favorite song of yours i
mean from the new album all over the
place
yeah i couldn't tell you i like all of
them
yeah i've heard every song it's great
but which song are you looking forward
to
the most i guess i'll give you the start
the first song
uh moment okay uh give us a little
uh i'll do a little rap for you um uh
okay yeah situated in my own lane i'm
not in it for the one time no piercer
my train always on the go
i needed an igloo for my shindu and then
added over there
with that money because i'm not a liar
[Music]
oh thank you bro ah bro i love you man
what is your most annoying habit
probably when i'm
eating and i slapped my lips yeah i i'm
allowed
interesting do you want to give us a
little demo oh i guess when i'm
yeah that's that's pretty yeah yeah i
i'm like
yeah that loud at least i cleaned the
toilet after i you know i do number two
yeah that is true i know people that
don't even do that skin marks left right
and center i know
many it's mud i know people who piss
with the seat down are you mental we
would never do something like that
nah what up and coming youtubers are you
excited about
um probably nico yeah yeah
nico oh that's his name yeah 100
i mean he's quite established these days
you know i'll give him that who else um
aiden ross
he's the one that's popping right now he
makes funny content
waiting people out with his antics but
uh it's funny
does anyone remind you of you right no i
know one
no one there's only one meme well
there's actually two and we're both fit
we are should we just get naked right
now just
stop making it out okay uh
if you were on death row what would be
your last meal
so i'm just getting lost in your eyes so
sorry uh what was the question again
if you were on death row what would be
your last meal
i don't know just probably just chicken
yeah so
nando's maybe yeah yeah i mean yeah we
all love nando's
uh what's your what's your favorite
spice uh
hot really no i'm kidding yeah
every medium would be medium i'm not
that black yeah yeah you're definitely
not
what has been your most reckless
purchase what's been my most
reckless purchase probably a 500 000
uh dollar chain wow what a waste of
money well i mean
obviously your boy had to you know get a
dragon ball
super chain got beerus the cat
and i hardly ever [ __ ] wear it so
what is it just locked in a second it's
literally just chilling in the bank
yeah it's what we doing
what's the point like why would you do
that how many times have you worn it
i've worn it less than 10 times i could
actually count on my hands
what's wrong with me oh man but it's
nice to look at at least
you can be so stupid sometimes love it i
love you too
all right what has been your career
highlight so far probably just
looking at you man yeah like this is a
huge
moment for me we are just meant to be
together
we are we're just so amazing the things
we've done
the people we've beaten in the ring oh
my god the accolades we've achieved in
music
the accolades we've achieved in youtube
we're just we're on fire we're
untouchable right now yeah this is the
most favorite interview that i've ever
done
bro this is the best interview i've ever
done
legit after this interview we got we got
a talk
and i'm talking sexually because i'm
turned on i'm [ __ ] tired jesus
what do you think about the 21 savage
future song oh mate
huge song big banger yeah when people
hear that it's going to be
mental got a music video for it everyone
oh yeah yeah
legion when people watch that crazy
what is your biggest guilty pleasure my
biggest guilty pleasure ah when i put on
the spot for these questions there ah
my biggest pleasure selling sunset on
netflix
that's my biggest guilty pleasure
because i just i really like looking at
them
they're nice houses nice houses yeah
should we get one i like looking at them
i like looking at them i think they're
overpriced personally